Let's go next to Ali Reza in Toronto,
Canada. Ali, Reza, you're on the air.
Ali Reza, please, on mute so that we can
hear you, you are on the air in Toronto,
Canada, but I cannot hear you until you
mute yourself and configure your audio.
And Ali Reza, absolute last opportunity,
it's sort of a going once, going twice,
going three times type of thing. And Ali Reza
is gone because Ali Reza was unable to put
everything together. Let's next go to Hamdi from
Norway, Hamdi from Norway. You're on the air.
Yeah, hello. Can you hear me? Yes, I can.
Yeah, do we have any specific point that
we have to hold to a specific point? Yeah,
like for example, I have a question regarding what
do you think that the people on the right side,
on the political spectrum. Yeah. Get away more
with lies compared to the people on the left side.
Beautiful. So when you say
they get away with them,
they get who isn't holding them. In
other words, when the right lies,
the left doesn't punish them for it, or it's the
right that doesn't punish the right for lying.
Well, both because people on the left, they
punish people from the left while the people
on the right, those stick together like like
it's like a crime with wolves, you know,
they stick together through thick and thin.
Right. I mean, it's different standards. This
is exactly the point. And I talked about
this a few weeks ago when I explained
that the Trump cult is they don't think about
facts and truth the way that we on the left do.
They believe that they are waging essentially
a war and that they have the moral high ground.
And so when Kayleigh McEnany comes out
and lies and Trump says he won Georgia
and people at the rally in Georgia say Fox now
is liberal and you have to listen to Newsmax,
they think that the it doesn't matter whether
they are telling the truth in a literal sense,
because they are in a war where any
tactic to win the war is acceptable.
The left doesn't have that perspective and the
left often will say we're not going to stoop to
their level. And this is why the right gets away
with lies that the left wouldn't even let its own
get away with. You're identifying this perfectly.
Yeah. For, for example, we have a saying as a.
As a region with from an immigrant family,
of course, North African from Western Sahara.
OK. So basically, my my my dad came in here in
1978, what I love about Norway, for example,
I never experienced racism, not
even once. Really such. Yeah,
such. We have a thing in Norway that's called
what in the moment, which to me is like our new in
our new people.
It's interesting to
hear you say that because, you know, one of the
arguments that American right wingers love to make
about Sweden, Norway and Finland is they
say the reason that there is no racism there
is that there's no people to be racist against
because everybody is white. But you're saying
even as someone who is in an overwhelming minority
there, you've never felt racism in that way?
Well, one thing is that what's fun about this is
that I hate the fact that Americans I'm sorry,
but Americans think that their country is
the only nation with immigrants. For example,
I'm from a city called Drammen and it's one of
the biggest cities in Norway. And you have Oslo,
which is like around 24 percent immigrant rights
people from immigrant background. So there's a lot
of immigrants in Norway. I think it's two percent
to two percent of the population is Muslim now,
and we have tons of Vietnamese as well.
I think that's higher than the United
States. I believe in the U.S. only one point
five percent is Muslim or something like that.
It might be one. So it's between one and two. The
biggest immigrant group we have here is Swedish
and Pakistanis and now Polish, I think, if I'm
not mistaken. OK, but we have immigrants from
all parts of the world, just like you guys have.
So it's not really that big of a difference. Yeah.
The thing about him I was going to ask really is
that I find it really strange that the people on
the right get away with racist terms without
when you called them out about it, they tried
to say they're not racist. For example, we have
people like you guys have Donald Trump. We have
someone called us as a female. I think there was
The Colbert Report maybe made fun of her because
she she are people in her party is a term that
called sneek Islamic setting, which is a sneaky
way of introducing. Yes. Sneaky Islamization, it
sounds like. Yeah. Yeah, basically. And I mean,
like if you said that stuff about Jews, like
sneaky Jews trying to invade our country, if it
did something like that, oh my God, you would
call that straight away, you know? Well, people do
say that all the time, interestingly enough. But
yes, you're right. There's no head of a political
party in Norway who says that about Jews. Right.
But somehow it's OK to say this about Muslims.
Yeah. I don't wonder why can people on the right
side get away with this with no consequences?
Yeah, it's well, it's because there's
their side. Doesn't think there should be
consequences. That's that's the that's the exact
difference. And, you know, people say, well,
the left allows the left to get away with the
same. No, they don't. It's like, you know,
here we have this Anthony Weiner scandal. As soon
as Anthony Weiner was caught with these texts,
Democrats just disavowed him. And that was it.
When there was a guy caught with ten thousand
dollars in his freezer for some bribe. It was like
a decade ago. Democrats weren't standing by him. I
forget his name now. So, yeah, it just they don't
they don't think there should be consequences
for some of these things. So then therefore
there are no consequences. It's that simple.
Yeah.
Well, yeah, Hamdi, listen,
I love the call, I've never been to Norway, but
it is high on my list and I would love to visit.
Yeah, would be great to have you here.
Now, I've been to Finland. What would
be if I liked Finland, what would be the most
notably different thing about Norway if I visited?
Yeah, well, basically, you say that, for
example, we have a company called Year Army,
which is one of the biggest companies in
Europe. So we opened section for Finnish people.
Well, the thing is about about Finnish. They're
known for being really quiet, not like they don't
like to talk that much to, you know, they're not
really sociable, but as long as soon as you give
them something to drink, they're really sociable.
But wages are more like they're more tolerant.
They're very left wing. And yeah, that's why I'm
saying never experienced racism here. People are
very open, very friendly. And yeah, I encourage
everybody to come over here and see for yourself.
I plan to. We used to have direct flights
from Boston to Oslo. Now who knows? You know,
but I will I will make it there
after the pandemic, my friend.
Yep. All right. Thank you so much for
the call. Very much. Appreciate it.
I'm sorry I was not able to take more
calls, but we got some good ones. I
will take calls again very soon.
We will go to a break and be back
with more right after this. The David
Pakman Show at David Pakman Dotcom.